i'm joined by the education secretary
nadim zahari good morning secretary of
state
can we just start with the um
state of play
yesterday
150
000
deaths looking back can we really say
that all of those deaths were
unavoidable
well of course we will learn the lessons
of how
we dealt with the pandemic through the
inquiry that we've announced
and
that is the right way to do this
one of those 150 000 was my uncle he was
eligible for a vaccine
sadly
he contracted covert before we could get
him
vaccinated so then um we had to wait for
that period but unfortunately
it became very severe and we lost him uh
to this uh evil virus
so it you know it brings it home to me
um and to many families that the 150 000
are not just
numbers statistics they are parents
grandparents uncles aunts
um husbands wives um so it is important
that we learn those lessons and that
inquiry
will be able to deliver that in the
meantime
we continue to deal with uh this virus
with omicron which is a you know the
infection rates are a quantum higher
than delta
but thankfully the booster seems to be
working incredibly well
and you look at the although the number
of people going into hospital is rising
still but actually the people on icu
has been coming down which
again demonstrates that the vaccines are
the best way out of this
pandemic because they uh again
weaken the link between infection rates
and severe infection of course
hospitalization and death uh thankfully
so
90
of um over 12 year olds now have had a
single uh vaccine which is great to see
that uptake and vaccine hesitancy
decreasing including of course over the
christmas period many people have never
been vaccinated came forward to be
actually and 90 over 50s have had a
booster and so um i'm confident that the
you know the way out of this and as we
transition this virus from pandemic to
endemic i hope will be one of the first
you ask me the question how well we've
performed i hope will be one of the
first major economies to demonstrate to
the world how you transition from
pandemic to endemic and then deal with
this however long it remains with us
with the five six seven ten years
i want to unpack that but just before we
leave the 150 000 figure
there will be families like your own
who
they will
i won't say look forward but they will
be anticipating the inquiry
but your relatives and families like
yours
probably already know that and this is
not pointing the finger but they
probably didn't already know
that much of what we did was too little
too late wasn't it
i don't agree with that and if you look
at my role in this with the vaccine uh
deployment oh the success well
but also we've heard we've had many
successes um so one of the the big
successes now obviously is the
antivirals and uh
javid the health secretaries ordered
over five million antivirals um of
course the success is testing we've
tested um you know twice as many people
in the uk than france has done i think
about four times and germany has done
over the past uh
two years we've done 400 million plus
tests if i tell you that in january
alone
we've ordered 425 million
lateral flow devices
people can get their tests schools
opened last week we are secondary
schools to test at school we got 31
million kits delivered because i got
them to order uh from november and we
had a different um uh supply chain four
schools we're going to get another 17.6
million out
by this week
and so there's many successes in terms
of our diagnostics uh capability we had
not much diagnosis capability to speak
of in the uk now we are a behemoth when
it comes to testing diagnosis and of
course uh vaccination not just for the
uk but rest of the world as well let's
let's talk about where we go from here
you have already said this morning that
you think that we are moving from
pandemic to endemic let's talk about
some of the signals of that um
when do you want the isolation period to
move from seven days to five days
so the uk health and security agency um
did a very good blog on this and your
viewers should actually have a look at
that and um what they looked at is
because people said you know the
america's at five days why are we at
seven days actually we begin our
isolation period when people get
symptoms in the u.s it's when they test
positive so we have to be careful
um as to whether we move because what
you could end up as an is actually a a
perverse incentive where where the
spike
is higher because people come out of
isolation too early but they said they
will review it and if the evidence is
there where if you are asymptomatic and
you are vaccinated and boosted and you
have two uh days a consecutive days of
negative lateral flow tests uh they said
they will keep keep that under review of
course it would help um
want that to happen as soon as possible
well i would
obviously always defer to the scientific
advice on this it would certainly um you
know help mitigate some of the pressures
on uh uh you know schools on critical
workforce and others but i would
absolutely be
um you know
driven by the advice from the experts
the scientists on whether we should move
to uh five days from seven days uh
otherwise what you don't want is
obviously to create um the the the wrong
outcome by higher levels of infection
well you want that to happen another uh
suggestion that's uh apparently coming
forward and i think you
are associated with this
that um
lateral flow tests at some point gonna
have to stop being free
uh if this is a
an endemic condition
when do you want that to happen i saw
that story this morning which i was
slightly puzzled by because i don't
recognize it at all this is absolutely
not where we are at on the contrary i've
just said to you in my opening remarks
that you know for january alone we've
got 425 million lateral floaters coming
in and they'll continue to be
available for free because actually
we've got three lines of defense the
booster and obviously vaccination if you
haven't been vaccinated testing and
antivirals and all those three things
are really so i don't really recognize
where that story's coming to be clear
there are no plans at the moment
absolutely not to
stop lateral flow test being free
absolutely not
um
the former former head of the vaccine
tax force task force says that we should
end
the mass vaccination campaign uh after
this booster round and move to
something called normality do you think
that's right
third booster and then we treat this
like normal annual flu well one of the
you know actually real great things we
have in the uk is people like clive dix
who you're referring to and of course
kate bingham and um
richard sykes who's now chairing the
vaccines task force and others who are
brilliant brits who are world experts in
this area so i would certainly look at
the evidence all i would say is actually
we know
that the booster campaign has worked
incredibly well in terms of preventing
infection but also in preventing
hospitalization
and so we want to continue with that i
would obviously you know look at what
the jcvi would say on this uh for future
variants because we are going to have to
live with this virus it will um deliver
other variants
this year next year and beyond and i
think the great thing is vaccines are
getting better so we're getting you know
uh polyvalent multivalent vaccines and
that will uh deliver
greater protection against many other
variants of the virus as well as of
course the antiviral so we will continue
to impress
live with it that's that's the future um
you're painting a pretty optimistic
picture this morning but
let's be clear from the amd wards of our
hospitals it doesn't quite look like
that ambulances are having to
wait to move patients into
bed you're bringing military personnel
in
to help health leaders saying they could
be 25 down in staff numbers staff
absence tripled since the beginning of
december the truth is
the system is already pretty near
collapse and that's today's problem
rather than the sunday uploads of
tomorrow isn't it
so
the first thing to say on that is the uh
ambulance units and we've got four
thousand now i think a 500 um increase
on what we had pre covered um the nhs
front line the nhs support staff have
done a tremendous job if you look at
the school the hospital with where we
are today absolutely so they are under
pressure because obviously of the uh um
quantum higher infection rates with
omicron versus delta and therefore that
seven-day isolation period um uh
associated with that but if you look at
the number of uh hospital trusts that
have declared a critical incident
there's 24. indeed right which is a lot
that is that
is about you know 130 plus hospital
trust out of that there's 24.
in 2017-18 23 um
hospital trust declared a critical
incident so it is a mechanism that the
nhs uses very well
in
at times of very high pressure on the
system the nhs is very good because
they've got this ability to digital
passport staff between trusts that's
also capable we are
launching um eight nightingale um sites
uh we are probably going beyond that
increased capacity as well there are now
ten thousand plus getting additional
nurses in the nhs i'm four thousand plus
additional doctors
of your output yes
what i'm putting to you however is that
there are doctors who are saying we're
on our knees
there are nurses who are saying
the shifts are uh not that we're
depleted in each shift there are people
who are saying that actually
we're not getting treatments because and
there are we've uh sky had report done
reports people who have lost relatives
because of the crisis in hospitals now
you can tell me all the things that
you're doing but the point is actually
the more you tell me that you're doing
the more i wonder if it's enough because
actually if you're doing all of this and
we're still having this situation
there's a crisis aren't you being a bit
complacent not at all it is a as as sad
as javelin said it is a a rocky few
weeks i would say this is a a really
tough time that's that is that is
absolutely right because obviously we've
got people who are absent because of uh
having to self-isolate but what we're
doing is doing everything we can to make
sure that uh the nhs has the ability uh
to ride out this uh bump in the road for
the virus
within that is the additional five
billion for just the six months of uh uh
uh
money being made available by the
chancellor richie sunak to help the nhs
uh weather this storm and that's the
right thing to do including by the way
for example
in one week we've had um
overseas nurses right something like
900 overseas nurses registered in one
week so we know that there are staffing
pressures but we're trying to mitigate
against them by recruiting more nurses
50 000 over this uh parliament um all
right doctor let me come and of course
the military helping okay other parts
let me come back to your own particular
responsibility um you're sending
ventilator kits to schools you've
mandated masks but you're not going to
know the effect of the return
are you sure you've done as much
as you could do
we are continuing to monitor the
situation so what we did was before
uh
christmas we made sure um schools um
ordered their kits for the testing
before that um in november we got 350
000 co2 monitors at the cost of 25
million pounds so that we can monitor
the atmosphere in the classrooms from
that
data we're able to model to say actually
we need about 8 000 air purifiers for
those
classrooms that need that you know the
help that they can't mitigate um
for making sure the air is circulated
and fresh in the classroom we're getting
those out uh this coming week obviously
we prioritize special uh schools and
schools in alternative provision because
those kids are the most vulnerable and
of course as of monday we continue the
school vaccination program do you feel
assured we're not going to have to send
children home or close close schools so
i will do everything in my power i was
at hammersmith academy uh last week and
i saw how brilliantly they did with
testing their pupils and getting back to
education school leaders
teachers by the way the support staff
and a big shout out for the support
staff because without them we couldn't
do any of this i'm confident we'll be
able to cope
um i don't want to cut you short no but
but i do want to talk to you about the
economy because of course that is
actually yes for most people the thing
that is um looming
um it's not looking great most people
are going to see
an actual cut in that in their take home
in april because of tax rises
we are likely to see an energy price
rise could be anything up to several
hundred pounds
a month for the average household and
right behind that woof inflation coming
down the track
why don't you reconsider as i think some
of your cabinet colleagues want the rise
in national insurance because the cost
of living is going to be catastrophic
rise could be catastrophic so let me
just pull you up on your first sentence
the the uk economy because of the action
we took
over covert and how we've cope with
omicron
is going to be one of the fastest
growing economies in the g20 yeah yeah
we can all we can have an argument about
gdp numbers what i want to talk to you
about is household budgets
and what people feel like right and so
what's the best way for for people to
cope with um the cost of living is to
have a job right we have the highest
level of employment um
hold on this is a great this is a great
this is a great answer but i'm talking
to you about people who have jobs yes
they are in work who are going to find
that there are hundreds of pounds coming
out of their packet because of your tax
rises deal with that right so allow me
to finish that point so who were those
people those people are the people on
universal credit right they're taking
the tape no some of them some of them
are so you keep going off into a
direction rather than the one that asks
them my question yeah
the average household yes a lot of whom
are in jobs yes not in receipts of
benefits yes they will feel the tax rise
and the price prices how why not deal
with that okay so the national living
wage going up to 9 pounds 50 in april
same time right the universal credit
taper does make a difference about a
thousand pounds for those who who are
probably finding it most difficult uh to
cope the energy price cap remains in
place half a billion pounds to local
government because they know which
families need the most help with those
utility bills half a billion pounds
going to them as well as the winter fuel
allowance which is a 140 pound rebate
that will rise to 150 pound in october
taking more people it was it takes 2.2
million people 2.7 million people in
october well people who you're not
talking about people are in work look
can they come in work why wouldn't they
we we we have we're in work trevor we we
we have we
we
we're coming to the end of this but uh
and i you know we can talk around this
uh a lot but
isn't the fundamental problem here that
your chancellor
doesn't appear to have a plan to
uh ease the pressure on household
budgets i know you can talk about the
people who are at the margins and so on
but the average household is what i'm
asking about
the business secretary doesn't seem to
have a new plan to support businesses
ravaged by covert no furlough or
anything like that um
you you
i don't know what you're going to do
about sick teachers but the point is the
government doesn't really feel like it's
got a plan to deal with this cost of
living crisis uh prime minister seems to
be saying put my hands together and then
pray no not true i tell you for what you
asked me about the nic right let's let's
look at that right
now we know that that 36 billion
is absolutely the right thing to do to
deal with adult social care and the and
the backlog of the nhs right
who's paying for it 14
of the highest earners
pay 50 of that rise
6.6 million of those who really are
right at the bottom of earning
pay nothing
for the nic okay so it's worth putting
in perspective it is as progressive as
you can be whilst delivering on adult
social care and the backlog of the nhs
that makes it okay
the business secretary is meeting
literally all the time to deal with the
energy
spike in gas prices i'm sorry i'm gonna
have to stop you because
we have other guests waiting and i am
sure you and i are going to have this
conversation many times in coming weeks
thank you for your time this morning
thank you